ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
BATES [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
BRADFORD CABRERA [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
THEY'RE AWESOME GALGIANI
[inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HUESO.
THE TIDE OF JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
MORE LOCK.
MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST BEYOND THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE-RISE WE WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER
THIS MORNING BY A GUEST CHAPLAIN.
SISTER MARIA COMBOS AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
BY SENATOR STERN.
AS WE BRING OURSELVES INTO
AWARENESS OF GOD'S PRESENCE
TODAY.
WE PRAY FOR ALL WHO STILL LONG
TO EXPERIENCE GOD'S HER HEART OF
MERCY. FOR ALL WHO SUFFER AND
STRUGGLE ALONE.
MAY THEY RECEIVE HE AND SUPPORT.
FOR ALL WHO EXPERIENCED
INJUSTICE AND PERSECUTION.
MAY THEY RECEIVE STRENGTH AND
COURAGE. FOR ALL WHO GRIEVE AND
MOURN.
MAY THEY RECEIVE COMFORT AND
PEACE.
GOD OF LOVE AND MERCY.
ALL THE DAYS OF OUR LIVES ARE IN
YOUR HANDS.
HELP US TO KNOW YOUR PRESENCE IN
EACH UNFOLDING EVENT.
YOUR ACTIVE.
ENABLING GRACE AND EVERY
CIRCUMSTANCE.
AND YOU'RE IN DURING CALL TO
FOLLOW YOU EVERYDAY WITH COURAGE
AND GRATITUDE.
AMEN.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL
.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS IF EVER WAY
TO THEIR SEATS WE'RE GOING TO
GET STARTED WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO INTRODUCED
DOUGLAS CROFT.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE SENATOR
BILLS CONSTITUENTS MISTER
DOUGLAS CROFT IS WIFE SUSAN
DOUGLAS WAS ONE OF THE
RECIPIENTS OF THE ANNUAL
WILDLIFE PHOTO OF THE YEAR
CONTEST.
PRESENTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
OUTDOOR CALIFORNIA MAGAZINE YOU
CAN SEE IS A PHOTOGRAPH OF A
HUMPBACK WHALE TAKEN AT THEM IN
MONTEREY BAY BUT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
CONGRADULATIONS DOUGLAS I
WELCOME TO YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
IN THE PICTURE IS HERE AT THE
BACK IN CHAMBERS.
SENATOR BILL FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO
YOU RISE.
OF THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
WE HAVE DOUGLAS AND THE PITCHER
ACTUALLY HERE ON THE FLOOR TODAY
FOR EVERYBODY TO LOOK AT AS I
JUST SAID THIS WILL BE --
DISPLAYED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE -- I
LIKE I I'M I'M VERY FOND OF THE
HUMPBACK WHALES IN THE MONTEREY
BAY IT'S REALLY ENJOYABLE TO GO
OUT AND SEE HIM --
ESPECIALLY SENSE --
THERE'S SO MANY OF THEM THIS
YEAR TO THIS YEAR IS A WONDERFUL
YEAR TO GO TO MONTEREY BAY AND
LOOK AT THE HUMPBACK WHALES.
SANTA BARBARA ALSO OKAY.
SO -- THANK
YOU DOUGLAS FOR THE PHOTO ID.
CONGRADULATIONS.
THANK YOU CENTRE BELL AND
CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN.
MEMBERS WE'RE STILL UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR I WOULD
LIKE TO GO.
TO MADAM PRO TEM TO INTRODUCE
MISTER DAVE LOW EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
RECOGNITION OF HIS RETIREMENT
MADAM PRO TEM.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND THANK YOU TO ALL MY
COLLEAGUES --
WHO I KNOW ARE LISTENING
ATTENTIVELY AT THIS MOMENT?
IT IS A I REALLY TRULY MY HONOR
TO INTRODUCE MISTER DAVE LOW ON
OUR SENATE FLOOR AS HE BEGINS A
WELL EARNED RETIREMENT.
I THINK I AND MANY OF US WANT TO
THANK DAVE FOR THIRTY EIGHT
YEARS OF SERVICE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION.
FIGHTING FOR ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
MAKE PUBLIC EDUCATION POSSIBLE
IN THE STATE.
HE STARTED HIS CAREER WITH CSEA
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE IS A
LABOR RELATIONS SPECIALIST IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
OVER THE YEARS HE WORKED HIS WAY
UP THE RANKS ULTIMATELY EARNING
APPOINTMENT AS THE SIX EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR.
OF CSTA IN.
TWENTY ELEVEN AS THE CHAIR OF
CALIFORNIA LABOR COALITION DAVE
HAS ALSO BEEN A CATALYST IN
CALIFORNIA'S BROADER LABOR
MOVEMENT HE'S BEEN IN THE MIDDLE
OF EVERY IMPORTANT DEBATE
AFFECTING WORKING PEOPLE.
FROM EDUCATION FUNDING TO
PENSIONS MEN CARE THE LIST GOES
ON AND ON AND ON DAVE HAS POURED
HIS HEART AND SOUL INTO HIS WORK.
AND CALIFORNIA IS BETTER FOR IT.
HE LEFT CSEA AND THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR MOVEMENT STRONGER THAN
EVER AND HE'S LEFT A LASTING
IMPRESSION ON MANY OF US IN THE
CAPITAL.
I'VE ENJOYED WORKING CLOSELY
WITH HIM BOTH IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND IN THE SENATE.
HEARING HIS INCREDIBLY JOYOUS
LAUGH THROUGHOUT THE HALLS.
BUT ALSO SEEING HIS SKILL AND
HIS DEDICATION IN ACTION.
AND OF NOTE OF COURSE I ALSO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE HIS INCREDIBLE
SPOUSE FRANCIS LOW.
IS ALSO PART OF OUR SENATE
FAMILY.
FRANCIS WORK FOR MANY YEARS AS A
CONSULTANT TO THE LABOR
COMMITTEE ND THE SENATE OFFICE
OF RESEARCH I THINK WE WISH YOU
BOTH ACTUALLY BUT DAVE ALONG
HAPPY RESTFUL RETIREMENT.
YOU'VE CERTAINLY EARNED IT AND I
CERTAINLY HOPE TO SEE BOTH OF
YOU MORE OFTEN IN MY DOWNTOWN
SAN DIEGO DISTRICT.
OR I KNOW THAT THEY WILL BE
ROOTING FOR THE BELOVED PADRES
NO MATTER WHAT THE RECORD.
SO COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
OFFERING OUR SINCERE THANKS AND
CONGRATULATIONS TODAY
[inaudible]
CONGRADULATIONS GAVE
ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS WE ARE STILL UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SENATOR DODD DID YOU HAVE A
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR
[inaudible]
SENATOR DODD [inaudible]
OKAY
[inaudible]
SENATOR DODD.
MATT A PRESENT FOR PURPOSES OF
ANNOUNCEMENT PLEASE PROCEED.
WELL THAT IS --
IT'S AN EXTREMELY HARD ACT TO
FOLLOW BUT MEMBERS I'M DELIGHTED
TO ANNOUNCE THAT MY OLDEST SON
JEFF AND HIS WIFE KELLY --
I HAD ARE NIGHT GAND CHILD --
TWO NIGHTS AGO.
WE HAVE A GERALD WILLIAMS DODD
AREA AND VERY VERY HEALTHY BOY
AND WE ARE JUST ABSOLUTELY
DELIGHTED.
THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS TO THE WHOLE
FAMILY SENATOR DODD.
MEMBERS WE ARE STILL UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SENATOR GROW FOR WHAT PURPOSE
YOU RISE FOR RECOGNITION THANK
YOU MADAM SLEAZE PROCEED.
MADAM PRESIDENT I APOLOGIZE
THAT'S OF A THING FROM THE FLOOR
ON THE OTHER SIDE RIGHT SO
MATTER HAS YOUR FUN THINGS
PROCEED I DO RISE AND WANT TO
THANK A SENATOR PATRICIA BATES
FOR HER LEADERSHIP FOR NEARLY
TWO YEARS SERVING.
THE CALIFORNIA AS SERVING AS
CALIFORNIA REPUBLICAN LEADER.
PAT CARES DEEPLY FOR OUR STATE
AND SHE UNDERSTANDS THE
STRUGGLES OF POVERTY AND
HARDSHIP AS A SOCIAL WORKER IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY PATRICK HAS
KNOWS FIRST HAND THE COUNTLESS
STORIES IT AFFECTED POVERTY.
IN THE UNDERSTAND THE MEETING
AND UNDERSTANDS THE MEANING OF
GETTING A HAND DEBT VERSUS A
HAND OUT.
AS A SUCCESSFUL ELECTED OFFICIAL
INS AS SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY
SIX PAT HAS A GOOD PULL CENTER
DISTRICT AND UNDERSTANDS ALL
OVER CONSTITUENTS NEEDS.
OVER THE YEARS PASS LEGISLATION
IS INCLUDE WERELIVING INDUSTRY
AND SUCCESSFULLY GOT LESS
LEGISLATION SIGNED INTO LAW TO
EDUCATE OUR YOUTH ABOUT OPIOID
ADDICTION.
AS A CHAMPION OF PUBLIC SAFETY
PAT IS PUSHED LEGISLATION TO
CLOSE A LOOPHOLE ONE PROP.
FIFTY SEVEN SHE'S A CLASSY
SOPHISTICATED REMARKABLE WOMAN
SHE'S THE SECOND WOMAN TO EVER
HOLD THE LEADERSHIP POSITION IN
OUR REPUBLICAN CAUCUS.
SHE'S UNITED ARE CAUCUS FOR THE%
COMMON GOOD.
WHEN I FIRST TALKED TO HER ABOUT
LEADERSHIP SHE SAID ALL BE THE
GRAMMA?
AND I THOUGHT WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN RIGHT AND THEN SHE WENT ON
TO EXPLAIN THAT SHE WOULD BE THE
WISE PERSON THAT IF I EVER HAD
ANY PROBLEMS I COULD COME.
TO SHE WOULD NEVER ABANDON ME IN
THIS NEW LEADERSHIP ROLE AND IF
I EVER NEEDED ANYTHING I COULD
REACH HER TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
AND THAT IS A REMARKABLE LEADER
THAT WILL NOT ABANDON THE
SUCCESSOR.
I JUST APPRECIATE THAT I LOOK
FORWARD AS A LEADER CAUCUS --
INTO THE FUTURE WITH MY FORMER
ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUE AND SENATE
PRO TEM TONI ATKINS TO DO GREAT
THINGS FOR OUR STATE MAKE
CALIFORNIA MORE AFFORDABLE.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT FRIEDMAN
ECONOMIC ADVANTAGE --
STRETCH ACROSS ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND I'M HONORED TO BE ABLE TO BE
SOMEONE WHO WILL HOPEFULLY BE
ABLE TO FILL HALF THE ISSUES
THAT ARE FORMER LEADER HAS SPENT
SO THANK YOU PAT FOR ALL YOU'VE
DONE FOR US.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROW.
THANK YOU SENATOR BAYH
.
NO.
A MADAM MADAM A OR A ERROR
SENATOR BATES MAY I GO TO MANTA
PRO TEM FIRST PLEASE SURE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR ATKINS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
AND THANK YOU.
SO MUCH FOR LETTING ME GO AHEAD
OF YOU BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE IF
YOU GOOD THINGS ARE.
AND THAT'S ALWAYS WELCOME I I
WANNA ALSO JOIN.
MY COLLEAGUE AND SAY THANK YOU
TO SENATOR BATES FOR SERVING
WITH CAN LEADER FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
I SHE WAS ELECTED TO THE SENATE
SHE'S BEEN A VERY STRONG
ADVOCATE AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID
FOR HER COMMUNITY IN HER
CONSTITUENTS.
AND IS AUTHORED LEGISLATION
EVERY YEAR TO COMBAT IN
PARTICULAR THE OPIOID CRISIS AND
I WANT TO GIVE MY PERSONAL
THANKS TO YOU FOR THAT THAT HAS
TOUCHED SO MANY LIVES.
NOT JUST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY THAT YOU'RE LEADERSHIP
ON THAT ISSUE IS GREATLY
APPRECIATED BY SO MANY WHO WILL
NEVER KNOW.
YOUR NAME.
BUT THAT'S THAT'S THE THE
WONDERFUL THING ABOUT THIS
OPPORTUNITY IN THIS JOB AND
ABOUT LEADERSHIP.
SENATOR BATES SAID IT BEST
GOVERNMENT WORKS BEST WHEN
PEOPLE WORK TOGETHER TO FIND THE
BEST PATH FORWARD FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
AND WE HAVE NUMBERS OF EXAMPLES
BUT I WANT TO THANK HER IN
PARTICULAR FOR WORKING --
TO AUTHOR A BILL A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO SB ONE NINETY SEVEN
THAT THEN ULTIMATELY OUR
MAJORITY LEADER.
I JOIN THE AND TO HELP CONSTRUCT
OR GET THE CONSTRUCTION OF A
MENTAL HEALTH FACILITY AT CAMP
PENDLETON.
I IN OUR COMMUNITY IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY.
SO I WANT TO THANK HER FOR HER
PARTNERSHIP FROM THE DAY THAT I
ARRIVED.
AND AND AS I STEPPED INTO THE
ROLE OF PRO TEM.
HER PRAGMATIC APPROACH HER NO
NONSENSE --
WAY OF DEALING WITH A I THINK IS
REALLY SERVICE HOUSE INCREDIBLY
WELL SO THANK YOU SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS.
I DO WANT TO CONGRATULATE MY
COLLEAGUE --
WE STARTED TOGETHER IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND CONGRATULATE
SENATOR GROW FOR HER SELECTION
IS THE NEW REPUBLICAN LEADER.
AS THE DAUGHTER.
OF SISTER AN AUNT AND NIECE OF
VETERANS OF THE US ARMED FORCES
I'M REALLY PLEASED TO SEE --
THAT THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS HAS
SELECTED A WOMAN AND A VETERAN
TO LEAD THE CAUCUS THAT ADDS A
NEW DIMENSION.
I HAD A SOMEONE WHO WAS BORN IN
RURAL AMERICA --
I THINK MOST PEOPLE DON'T QUITE
REALIZE THAT THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER AND I SHARE WAY MORE IN
COMMON THAN YOU MIGHT REALIZE.
NOW I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT'S
GOING TO MAKE YOU FEEL --
BUT I WOULD SAY --
AS I WOULD ALSO SAY ABOUT OUR
INCREDIBLE REPUBLICAN LEADER AT
MS BATES AND TO MS GROVE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN --
THE PRO TO HIM AND THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER AT THIS POINT
IS A UNIQUE RELATIONSHIP.
AND I THINK THAT --
BATES AND I KNOW THAT MY
COLLEAGUE --
MS GROVE WILL WORK TO TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS HOUSE THE SENATE
HOUSE -- IS
RESPONSIBLE TO ALL OF YOU
COLLECTIVELY AS A GROUP.
AND I JUST HAVE APPRECIATED THE
WISE COUNSEL AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT WISE
COUNSEL --
WITH MISS BATES AND I LOOK
FORWARD MISS GROW FOR SO THANK
YOU AND I'M GOING TO JUST ASSUME
THAT YOUR WONDERFUL GIFT OF
FLOWERS TO MISS BATES WAS FOR
MONTHS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS
[inaudible]
SENATOR BATES. TO GIVE YOU.
I'M POLITICIANS ARE NOT SUPPOSED
TO BE SPEECHLESS IN FACT WE'RE
PROBABLY OF OVERLY FULL OF
SPEECHES VETAR I'M SPEECHLESS
BECAUSE THIS IS TOTALLY.
UNEXPECTED SO LET LET ME SAY. TO
ALL OF YOU IF INCREDIBLE HONOR
TO BE IN THIS HOUSE AND I THINK
YOU ALL FEEL THAT.
ARE THOSE OF US WHO SERVED FOR A
WHILE IN THOSE WHO ARE NEW --
IT IS A VERY SPECIAL PLACE ARE
WHERE WE LEAVE OUR DISAGREEMENTS
OUT THERE AND WE COME TOGETHER
HERE AND HAVE WHAT I CONSIDER TO
BE THE MOST IMPORTANT PART OF
OUR DEMOCRACY.
VERY GOOD DISCUSSION AND DEBATE --
WE WIND UP YOU KNOW WITH YOU
KNOW COULD BE A UNANIMOUS OR WE
HAVE SPLIT BILLS THAT WITH GREAT
RESPECT BECAUSE WE'RE ALL HERE
TO DO OF THE VERY SAME THING IS.
TO SHARE OUR EXPERIENCE AND
CERTAINLY ARC.
SO IT'S BEEN MY HONOR TO SERVE
OUR OUT WITHOUT.
PRO TâM IT WAS A IT'S BEEN SO
MUCH FUN ARE.
YOU KNOW HAVING TO WOMEN AND
CRIME I DON'T GET INTO THAT YOU
GUYS BUT IT HAS BEEN GREAT
BECAUSE I GO BACK YOU KNOW.
YOU KNOW I WAS BORN BIKE.
WELL.
ACTUALLY THE BEGINNING A WORLD
WAR TWO SO I'M PROBABLY THE
SENIOR MEMBER REAL SENIOR HERE
BUT TO SEE THAT WOMEN HAVE MADE
SUCH A ON ADVANCEMENT WE ARE
BASICALLY CHEN NON GENDER YOU
KNOW WE'RE ALL HERE.
ARE SERVING THE SAME PURPOSE AND
WE'VE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SUCCEED AND FOR THOSE WHO HAD
MOTHERS LIKE IDEA. TO CAMP Là
WHO WORK JUST SO I COULD GO TO
COLLEGE AND HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GO TO COLLEGE WHILE SHE
ACTUALLY HAD TO QUIT SCHOOL IN
THE EIGHTH GRADE BECAUSE THEY
WERE SO VERY POOR AT THAT TIME.
SO WE MADE GREAT PROGRESS AND
NOW WE HAVE WOMEN LEADING US AND
THERE ARE HONORING ME IS LIKE
GOTTA BE KIDDING BECAUSE THIS IS
BE AND CERTAINLY ALL LIFE PATH
THAT I THINK THE THE CREATOR PUT
ME ON THE THANK YOU GUYS BEEN AN
HONOR TO SERVE YOU ALL.
I AM HERE FOR A FEW MORE YEARS
AND I INTEND TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ALL OF YOU TO DO OUR VERY
BEST FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I LOVE YOU ALL AND I HOPE THAT
WE WILL YOU KNOW ALWAYS BE
COLLEAGUES HERE AND GOING
FORWARD SO THANK YOU AND I WAS
SPEECHLESS BUT I KEPT ON TALKING
SAUCE.
ITHANK YOU SENATOR BATES
[inaudible]
SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IN --
MEMBERS OF YES INDULGE ME JUST A
COUPLE OF MINUTES BECAUSE I WANT
TO PAY TRIBUTE.
TO MY VERY DEAR FRIEND --
PAT BATES WHEN I CAME TO THIS
INSTITUTION --
FOUR YEARS AGO --
I DID KNOW PAT BATES UNTIL IF I
I DON'T KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE
HERE IN THE SENATE BECAUSE I
WASN'T THE A WONDERFUL
FRIENDSHIP AND I GOT TO KNOW PAT
REALLY WELL AND WE ACTUALLY.
TRY TO GO OUT TO DINNER ABOUT
ONCE A WEEK AND MANY TIMES I'LL
BE TALKING TO MY WIFE AND I SAY --
I GOT TO GO I'M I'M HAVING
DINNER WITH MY GIRLFRIEND
TONIGHT.
AND SHE KNEW AND SHE KNEW VERY
WELL WHAT I WAS TALKING ABOUT
BECAUSE SHE SHE KNOWS PAT AND
SHE LOVES PAT AND THE ONE THING
I LIKE ABOUT PAT IS THAT SHE'S
VERY ALTRUISTIC.
AND SHE'S VERY UNDERSTANDING.
AND HE'S TAUGHT ME SO MUCH ABOUT
PARTISAN POLITICS AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT COMING FROM THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS WERE THINGS WERE
MUCH LESS POLITICAL THAN THEY
ARE HERE.
IT WAS A MUCH MORE RELAXED FULL
ENVIRONMENT --
SO HAD AS YOU KNOW IS A VERY
EVEN TEMPERED PERSON AND AS YOU
NOTICE MY MY DEMEANOR HAS KIND
OF CALMED AND IT'S BECAUSE OF
MAYBE BECAUSE OF THE WOMEN
LEADERSHIP OF THIS INSTITUTION
WHERE I THINK IT'S BEEN VERY
HEALTHY.
AND I WANT TO THE PROBABLY THE
MOST.
CHALLENGING PERSON HERE THAT HAS
HAS A JOB IS IS ARE WONDERFUL
PRO TEM AND I SAY WONDERFUL
BECAUSE I REALLY MEAN AND I
THINK SHE'S BEEN A WONDERFUL
LEADER SHE'S BEEN VERY FAIR --
VERY RESPONSIVE.
TO LEAST UP MY OFFICE AND I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES.
AND THEN THE SECOND MOST
DIFFICULT OFFICE IS CERTAINLY --
THE REPUBLICAN LEADER AND IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE RESPECT
BOTH OF THEM SO THEY CAN
INTERACT WITH ONE ANOTHER AND
AND OVERCOME ISSUES AND BIG
SHOES OFF THE FLOOR.
IN THE COMMON THINGS THAT I'VE
HEARD FROM BOTH OUR PRO TEM IN
OUR AND OUR REPUBLICAN LEADER IS
A WE WANT TO HAVE COLLEGIALITY
HERE IN THE SENATE WE'VE ALWAYS
BEEN KNOWN FOR A COLLEGIALITY.
AND PROFESSIONALISM AND
FRIENDSHIPS AND I THINK WITH THE
GREAT LEADERSHIP THAT WE SEEM
FROM THESE TWO MAGNIFICENT WOMEN
THAT WE ACHIEVE THAT.
IN A WAY IN WHICH I HAVEN'T SEEN
IN MANY MANY YEARS SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU MATTER PRO TEM AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU PAT BATES. FOR
THE WONDERFUL FRIENDSHIP THAT
BEGAN HERE WERE VERY CLOSE
FRIENDS I LOVE YOU DEARLY AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
FOR THE REMAINING TIME THAT YOU
HAVE HERE IN THE SENATE AND I
KNOW THAT YOU'RE GONNA WANT TO
CONTINUE TO DO.
YOUR WONDERFUL PUBLIC SERVICE
FOR ON BEHALF OF FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE LOOK UP TO YOU.
AS A WONDERFUL LEADER IN THE
CITY CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR STONE.
MEMBERS OF THERE ARE NO FURTHER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR WE WILL
MOVE TO MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WHICH WILL BE DEEMED
READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WHICH
WILL BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WHICH WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR FEBRUARY TWENTY
FIFTH THROUGH TWENTY EIGHTH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK.
WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
YES I'M SORRY CENTER JACKSON YES
WELL THANK YOU.
BRIEFLY UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS I WOULD LIKE --
TO ASHTON FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
THIS YEAR EIGHTEEN BE MOVED TO
THE INACTIVE FILE THANK YOU
SENATOR JACKSON ANYONE ELSE HAVE
ANYTHING THAT SHOULD BE MOVED
FROM THE TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL MOVE TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE THREE ITEMS UNDER THE
DAILY FILE ITEM SIX ELEVEN IN.
TWELVE CENTER LEYVA WILL BE
TAKING UP ITEM SIX MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR LEYVA
RELATIVE TO READ ACROSS AMERICA
DAY MORNING CENTER LABOR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY AS A PROUD JOINT
AUTHOR OF S. C. R. SEVENTEEN
WHICH RECOGNIZES MARCH FIRST TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AS READ ACROSS
AMERICA.
DAY DATING BACK TO NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT READ ACROSS AMERICA
DAY IS AN ANNUAL READING
MOTIVATION AND AWARENESS PROGRAM
THAT CALLS FOR EVERY CHILD IN
EVERY COMMUNITY TO CELEBRATE
READING.
TEACHING YOUNG CHILDREN TO READ
HELP THEM DEVELOP THEIR LANGUAGE
SKILLS CONCENTRATION CONFIDENCE
AND ABILITY TO AMPLIFY THEIR
IMAGINATION ALL TOO OFTEN THE
BARRIERS FACED BY CHILDREN WITH
DIFFICULTY READING.
OUTWEIGH THE DESIRE TO LEARN
WITHOUT PROPER GUIDANCE THEY MAY
NEVER OVERCOME THEM.
READING IS THE BUILDING BLOCK TO
LEARNING AND A FOUNDATION OF
FUTURE SUCCESS.
THIS MAJOR IS ESSENTIAL TO
ENCOURAGED FULL LIFE LONG
READERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE SENATORS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR LAST CALL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR IN THIS ITEM.
XENON MENTOR SECTOR CAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS.
I BATES.
AYE BELL [inaudible]
I FORGES.
I BRADFORD.
AYE CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I THEY'RE AWESOME [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible] FIVE GROWTH
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible] FIVE HUESO.
I TADA [inaudible] FIVE JACKSON
[inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING. FIVE MORE LOOK
[inaudible]
I MOREAU [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible] FIVE
RAW [inaudible] FIVE REVIEW
[inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I AMBER.
I WHITE HOUSE HE FIVE WIENER
[inaudible]
I WILK. FIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
BY. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT KNOW ZERO
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MEMBERS WE'RE GOINGTO REMOVE TO
FILE ITEM ELEVEN SENATOR DODD.
MISTERS MS SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION TWENTY BY
SENATOR DODD RELATIVE TO PROBLEM
GAMBLING AWARENESS MONTH SENATOR
DODD META PRESIDENT MEMBERS AS
CHAIR OF THE SENATE GEO
COMMITTEE I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
SENATE RESOLUTION.
TWENTY WHICH RECOGNIZES MARCH
TWENTY NINETEEN AS PROBLEM
GAMBLING AWARENESS MONTH IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ALTHOUGH MOST PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
GAMBLE RESPONSIBLY FOR SOME IT
BECOMES A DEVASTATING ADDICTION
THAT AFFECTS NOT ONLY THE
INDIVIDUAL BUT THEIR LOVED ONES
AS WELL.
FORTUNATELY GAMBLING ADDICTION
IS TREATABLE THAT IS WHY DURING
THE MONTH OF MARCH ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE COME
TOGETHER TO EDUCATE THE PUBLIC
AND HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS.
ABOUT THE WARNING SIGNS A
PROBLEM GAMING.
THIS RESOLUTION WILL RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE HELP FOR
THAT THE HELP THAT IS AVAILABLE
BOTH LOCALLY AND NATIONALLY FOR
PROBLEM GAMBLERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
I WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF
THE G. O. COMMITTEE FOR CO
AUTHORING THIS RESOLUTION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD SENATOR
PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESS.
SENATORS. TO AND IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION I THINK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM NAPA FOR BRINGING
THIS.
UP --
PARTICULARLY SINCE A A PROBLEM
GAMBLING ACTUALLY IS A
PARTICULAR ISSUE IN THE EIGHTY
AYE COMMUNITY AND FACT ACTUALLY --
OFTENTIMES EIGHTY AYE ARE
TARGETED BY.
ESTABLISHMENTS BECAUSE THERE'S
LESS OF A I THINK CULTURAL IN
ADDITION ABOUT GAMBLING --
SO I REALLY APPRECIATED THIS
RESOLUTION BEING BROUGHT UP US
ONLY HOPE THAT --
EFFORTS TO DRESS PROBLEM
GAMBLING OF COURSE AFFECTS ALL
PARTS OF OUR STATE AND OUR
POPULATIONS BUT PARTICULARLY TO
GIVE ATTENTION TO THE API
COMMUNITY AND BEING SURE THAT --
WE HAVE --
OUT REACH AND TREATMENTS THAT
ARE TAILORED FOR THE API
COMMUNITY --
IN THIS REGARD SO AGAIN THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND I TO AYE VOTE ON
THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN THE NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING OUR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE EYES
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SENATOR
ACTIONS.
THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION TWENTY TWO BY
SENATOR ATKINS RELATIVE TO THE
ELECTION OF MEMBERS ON THIS OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES.
CENTER ACTIONS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT SR
TWENTY TWO WHICH CHANGES THE
MEMBERSHIP OF THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE SPECIFICALLY THE
RESOLUTION APPOINT SENATOR BATES
TO THE COMMITTEE AND REMOVE
SENATOR GROVE I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS MEMBERS
THIS RESOLUTION WILL BE ADOPTED
BY A VOICE VOTE.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE
[inaudible]
OPPOSE NO.
THE AYES HAVE IT AND THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WE ARE MOVING ON TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS
WOULD BE THE APPROPRIATE TIME
FOR A GERMAN IN MEMORIES.
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
MADAM PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS OF I RISE TODAY TO JOIN
IN MEMORY OF ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS FILIPPI ELLEN
SIERRA.
A PROMINENT ATTORNEY AND
ACTIVISTS.
POSSIBLE ANSWER WOULD BORN IN
JALISCO MEXICO IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE AT THE AGE OF SEVEN HE
EMIGRATED TO SANTA ANA WITH HIS
PARENTS RAPHAEL.
MAHDIA IS THREE BROTHERS AND
SISTERS.
SNCF.
ATTENDED LOS AMIGOS HIGH SCHOOL
IN FOUNTAIN VALLEY.
IN WELL AT LOS AMIGOS HE
DISTINGUISHED HIMSELF
ACADEMICALLY.
WHO IS THE TOP VARSITY ATHLETE
THE SOCCER CROSS COUNTRY TRACK
TEAM [inaudible]
HE ALSO.
DID THIS WHILE WORKING IN A
NUMBER OF JOBS THROUGHOUT HIS
CHILDHOOD TO CONTRIBUTE. TO HIS
FAMILY AND IN THE HOUSE VOTE.
BUT SAID THE ATTENDED CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY FULLERTON WE
OBTAINED A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
PHILOSOPHY.
IN A ALSO MET.
AND MARRIED HIS WIFE YOLANDA
BENITO.
WELL AN UNDERGRADUATE PLACENTA
OF ACTIVELY PARTICIPATED IN
STUDENT ORGANIZATION TO ADVOCATE
ON BEHALF OF LATINOS.
AND OTHER MINORITY STUDENTS.
FULLY BUT WENT ON TO ATTEND
LOYOLA HIGH SCHOOL.
AND I'M SORRY AT LOYOLA LAW
SCHOOL WHERE HE CONTINUED HIS
WORK FOCUSING ON ISSUES.
THAT IMPACTED.
THE WORKING POOR AND UNDERSERVED
IMMIGRANTS PRIOR TO OPENING HIS
PRACTICE VALENCIA SERVED AS A
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DEPUTY.
PUBLIC DEFENDER DEPUTY CITY
ATTORNEY FOR THE CITY OF COMPTON
[inaudible]
ALONG --
WIFE STUDENT OF PHILOSOPHY IN
HUMAN NATURE PALENCIA ENCOURAGE
LAWYERS TO EMPATHIZE.
WITH ALL THOSE WHO INVOLVED IN
THE LEGAL PROCESS AND THE ROLE
PLAY FOR THE PERSPECTIVES OF ALL
PARTICIPANTS.
IN CASES BEFORE TRIAL BUT CENTER
WAS KNOWN FOR HIS CHARM AND DOWN
TO EARTH STYLE IN FRONT OF THE
JURY.
AND RELENTLESS ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF ITS CLIENTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE HE WAS
RECOGNIZED BUDGET TURNING OF THE
YEAR BY THE MEXICAN AMERICAN BAR
ASSOCIATION HE SERVED AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE MEXICAN
AMERICAN BAR ASSOCIATION.
POLITICAL ACTION COMMITTEE FROM
TWO THOUSAND FIVE UNTIL
PRESIDENT.
HIS LIFE WAS TRAGICALLY CUT
SHORT THIS LAST WEEK WHEN
RETURNING FROM COURT APPEARANCE
IN SAN LUIS OBISPO THE TWIN
ENGINE BEECHCRAFT.
HE WAS IN WENT DOWN INTO HAD
SHIPPING MOUNTAINS.
MISTER FLETCHER.
WAS IT RESIDENT LA HABRA HEIGHTS
MY DISTRICT.
AND HE SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE YOU
LANDA.
AND HIS DAUGHTERS MAKE GALLEY
ALINA HIS FATHER RAPHAEL IN A
SIBLING FOR A MOAN.
RASA VOICES RAFAEL [inaudible]
JOSE [inaudible]
AND ERICA.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS MADAM.
UP PRESIDENT I ASKED WE DURING
HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
CENTER HUESO ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
JUST WANTED TO RISE TO ALSO ADD
MY CONDOLENCES AND THANK MY
COLLEAGUE.
FROM LOS ANGELES ON ON ON THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON CALIFORNIA MEXICO COOPERATION
I CAN TELL YOU THAT --
PLACENCIA WAS A A A A VERY
IMPORTANT RESOURCE FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND HIS
EFFORTS TO BUILD BRIDGES.
BETWEEN OUR RESPECTIVE COUNTRIES
AND COMMUNITIES AND I KNOW HIM
AS SOMEBODY.
THAT WORKED REALLY HARD TO
PROMOTE --
THE FRIENDSHIP.
BUILDING BONDS --
EXCHANGING OF CULTURAL AWARENESS
WORKING VERY HARD AT THAT A IN
THAT LEVEL I KNOW THERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
IN IN MEXICO RIGHT NOW THAT
BUILT RELATIONSHIPS WITH WITH
HIM THAT ARE ARE ARE DEEPLY
SURPRISED AND IN MOURNING.
A TODAY AND I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
A VERY HOW HEARTFELT CONDOLENCES
TO HIS FAMILY AND TO THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY THAT'S LET
LOST A VERY IMPORTANT PERSON
TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO CENTER
RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I ALSO
RISE -- AND
I WON'T WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM.
THE RIVER ON SAN DIEGO FOR ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGING THE PASSING OF UP
PHILIP IT PLUS SENSE YEAH HE WAS
SOMEONE THAT WAS SO WELL KNOWN
IN.
THE LATINO COMMUNITY ALWAYS
WORKING TO HELP THOSE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN
PARTICULAR ELECTED OFFICIALS
ALWAYS PROMOTING THEM TRYING TO
RECOGNIZE I'M AND I KNOW THAT
EVERYONE LOOKED FORWARD TO HIS
YEARLY MOP UP PAKI VENDETTAS
HOME.
HE ALWAYS CELEBRATED EVERY
ELECTED THAT HAD DAM CONTRIBUTED
IN A POSITIVE WAY JUST TRYING TO
RECOGNIZE OUR WORK.
BUT TODAY IN PARTICULAR I RISE
FROM DEAR FRIEND I MISTER
PLACENCIA.
THEY WERE FRIENDS FOR THIRTY
FIVE YEARS IN ON HIS BEHALF I
WANT TO READ.
A STATEMENT FROM HIM.
HE WROTE OBJECTION IT IS WITH
EXTREME SADNESS AND A HEAVY
HEART.
THAT I SHARE THE PATH YOU KNOW
MY BEST FRIEND OF THIRTY FIVE
YEARS.
HAD COMPILED A AS HE WOULD LIKE
TO CALL HIM EVERY DAY.
HIS FRIEND PHILIP A PLACENCIA
PHILIP IT WAS NOT ONLY AN
AMAZING ATTORNEY BUT A GREAT
FRIEND.
VERY GIVING CARING INDIVIDUAL HE
WAS A REAL GENUINE SUPPORTER OF
EDUCATION AND GIVING TO OTHERS.
HIS NO NONSENSE ATTITUDE AND A
STRONG CHARACTER MADE HIM A
FORCE TO BE RECKONED WITH.
IN AND OUT OF THE COURTROOM MY
SINCERE CONDOLENCES GO.
TO MICHAEL MOTHER YOUR LEE.
AND MY BEAUTIFUL GOD DAUGHTERS
MY GODLY AND ALINA.
WE ARE BETTER NEGOTIATORS
ARBITRATORS HE CAN'T THERE
BECAUSE OF MY FRIEND FIFTY BY
PLACENCIA THANK YOU MY
CONDOLENCES GO TO THE FAMILY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO SENATOR
ALAN YEAH I JUST WANT TO ADD MY
VOICE -- IN
IN THAT IN MID MORNING PHILLIP
BAY WHO I WASN'T WAS OF ALL THE
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN DESCRIBED
HE ALSO WAS A VERY TALENTED
LAWYER --
WHO PROBLEMS OF A FROM HIS
BOOTSTRAPS BUILT A VERY
SUCCESSFUL CAREER AND THEN
DECIDED TO GIVE BACK HE ENGAGED
IN?
ALL SORTS OF BAR ACTIVITIES HE
BECAME A BIG LEADER IN THE NEXT
AMERICAN BAR ASSOCIATION.
AND WAS ALWAYS VERY ENCOURAGING
OF YOUNG WITH IN THAT --
LAWYERS WHO WERE COMING UP THE
RANKS AND HE WAS SOMEONE WHO
JUST HAD AN INCREDIBLY BIG HEART.
A IT WAS SO SHOCKING WHEN WE
FOUND OUT THE NEWS --
THE THE REVERBERATIONS OF GOD
THROUGHOUT THE LEGAL COMMUNITY
MY DISTRICT AS WELL BECAUSE YOU
HAD MANY VERY GOOD FRIENDS IT
CAME UP THIS WEEKEND WHEN I WAS
DOWN OF MY DISTRICT.
AMONG SOME OF MY FRIENDS IN THE
LEGAL COMMUNITY --
HIS LOSS IS FELT ALL THROUGHOUT
THE SOUTH LAND AND I HAD MY
VOICE IN THE JOURNEY IS MEMORY.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN AND
SENATOR CHILL TO MAKE SURE YO
BRING HIS SAME FORWARDS WE CAN
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE HIM
[inaudible]
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MATTER BROWN AGAIN I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY A TO THE
FAMILY OUR CONDOLENCES.
BUT TO THE MEN AND WOMEN.
OF BOTH HOUSES THE ASSEMBLY IN
THE SENATE WHO PRACTICE LAW OVER
THE YEARS AND THOSE WHO YOU.
ALWAYS WE TURN TO OUR LEGAL
COLLEAGUES AND FRIENDS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS TO PRACTICE LAW
WE'VE LOST A GOOD.
ONE AND I THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO OF BRING HIS NAME FORWARD
AND TO ACKNOWLEDGE HIM AND HIS
FAMILY IN THIS TERRIBLE TRAGEDY.
THANK YOU MAN PRESS.
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHER LETTER
LETTER THUNDER GLAZER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
IT'S WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I
ASK THE SENATE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF MATALIN MATTY HEARD A
STUDENT FROM MY DISTRICT WHO
TRAGICALLY LOST HER LIFE IN A
CAR CRASH.
IN ICY CONDITIONS THAT SHE WAS
DRIVING TOUR WEEKEND JOB AS A
SKI INSTRUCTOR --
MATTY WAS ONLY TWENTY ONE YEARS
OLD.
HE WAS A THRIVING AS A STUDENT
AT WESTERN WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY.
WORKING TOWARDS A DEGREE IN
RECREATION WAS ON TRACK TO
GRADUATE IN JUNE.
CHOOSE LOVE BUYER FELLOW
STUDENTS PROFESSORS AND SKI
INSTRUCTORS.
THE CHAIRMAN OF WESTERN
WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY'S
RECREATION PROGRAM.
KEITH RUSSELL SAID THAT MADDIE
WILL BE GREATLY MISSED SHE WAS A
GOOD FRIEND OF HER FELLOW
STUDENTS HE SAID.
HE SUPPORTED THEM AND INSPIRED
THE ATTY ALWAYS SAW THE BEST IN
PEOPLE SHE RECENTLY.
VOLUNTEERED HER TIME TO HELP
TROUBLED KIDS LEARN TO SKI.
SHE WAS A TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
GRADUATE OF CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOL IN SAN RAMON.
USE ACTIVE MEMBER THE SCHOOLS
LEADERSHIP PROGRAM --
MEMBER THE SWIM TEAM AND A FOUR
YEAR LETTER WHAT WOMAN FOR THE
VARSITY WATER POLO TEAM.
MY DEEP CONDOLENCES TO MADDY'S
PARENTS ALEX AND RACHEL HURD.
AN OLDER BROTHER STAND --
AND ADAM WITH THAT MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR JOINING
AND HER WONDERFUL MEMORY.
THE U. CENTER GLAZER PLEASE
BRING HER NAME FORWARD SO SHE
CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED.
SENATOR OR TO LET I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE ANOTHER ADJOURN
[inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN MADAM
PRESIDENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
I RISE WITH PROFOUND SADNESS
THAT I RISE TODAY. TO JOIN IN
MEMORY OF RETIRED MONTEBELLO
POLICE OFFICERS SERGEANT.
SALVADOR MARTINEZ TO ALL OF US
WHO KNEW HIM WELL WE CAUGHT
HIMSELF.
BUT BEFORE I GO ON LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN.
ALL OF US WHO LOVE OUR MEN AND
WOMEN IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHO'VE BEEN THERE WHO VOTED FOR
THEM SUPPORTED THEM THROUGHOUT
YOUR COMMUNITIES EVERYONE OF YOU
WHO HAS FAMILY MEMBERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THIS IS MY FAMILY THIS IS A
FRIEND OF MINE WHO I SHARED WITH.
WHO IDEA PARTNERED UP WITH?
AND WE WENT OUT AND DID WHAT WE
HAD TO DO BRING --
PEACE AND HARMONY TO OUR CITY OF
MONTEBELLO WE WORKED TOGETHER
FOR TEN YEARS.
SO AGAIN I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
SAY THAT SELL.
BEGIN HIS LAW ENFORCEMENT CAREER
WITH THE OF ZEUS UP POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
JUST OUTSIDE MY DISTRICT AND I
BELIEVE IT'S IN YOUR DISTRICT.
OF THE CENTER RUBIO.
HE BEGAN THERE IN IN THE IN THE
ZOO'S UP AS A RESERVE POLICE
OFFICER NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE AND
JOINED.
OF FULL TIME FOR THE CITY OF
AZUSA.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE SELL THE
JOIN THE MONTEBELLO POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN MAY OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN JUDGMENT.
WORKED A VARIETY OF ASSIGNMENTS
DURING HIS CAREER IN MONTEBELLO.
THE ASSIGNMENTS INCLUDED SENIOR
OFFICER FIELD TRAINING OFFICER
TRAFFIC.
OFFICER MOTOR OFFICER A
NARCOTICS DETECTIVE.
IN THAT UNIT I WAS SO PROUD TO
SERVE WITH HIM AS HE SEEMED TO
KNOW EVERYTHING THERE WAS TO
KNOW ABOUT NARCOTICS AND HE
TAUGHT ME QUITE A BIT.
ITSELF WAS PROMOTED TO SERGEANT
IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN ANY
WORKERS PATROL SERGEANT TRAFFIC.
AFTER THE SIMON A TRAFFIC WAS
COMPLETED IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE HE RETURNED TO WORK.
AS A PATROL SUPERVISOR UNTIL IT
RETIREMENT AND TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO AND AS A SUPERVISOR THIS IS
WHERE EVERYONE IN THE DEPARTMENT
FELT WHAT A LEADER WE HAD.
WHAT A COMPADRE WE HAD IN HIM?
IT'S DEFINITELY WORTH A COP'S
COP.
INTO A DEFINITE LEADER IN THE
DEPARTMENT.
RESULT IN UNIFORM ARE VETERANS
HE WAS A MARINE.
A RECORD VETERAN ANY WAS VERY
PROUD OF HIS SERVICE FOR THE
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS.
AND WE WOULD ROAD TOGETHER.
WE WOULD JOKE WITH WITH ONE
ANOTHER I BEING A PAIR TO PERM
HE BEING A MARINE.
THERE WAS ALWAYS THE FLIP OF A
COIN AND SEE WHO WOULD BUY LUNCH
OR WHO WOULD BUY DINNER.
BUT HE WAS ALWAYS LAUGHING AND
IT WAS A GREAT GUY AND I AYE MR
DEARLY.
HIS LOVE OF GOD AND COUNTRY
WOULD SHARE WITH ALL OF US WHO
KNEW HIM.
BUT IT WAS HIS BRAVERY THAT
STOOD OUT.
CELL WAS AWARDED THE MEDAL OF
LIFESAVING AND MIDDLE OF COURAGE
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE THE MEDAL
OF MERIT NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY.
AND ALL THROUGHOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT THIS IS SO VERY
IMPORTANT.
HE RECEIVED THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
HIGHEST REWARD THE MEDAL OF
VALOR IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT HE WILL BE
MISSED BY HIS FAMILY.
FELLOW VETERANS AND ALL WHO
HONORED WHO WERE HONORED TO KNOW
HIM TO WORK WITH HIM.
AND I'M SO HONORED THE CHURCH
CURRENT CHIEF OF POLICE HAS
ASKED ME TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
CEREMONY.
TOMORROW NIGHT.
WHERE MEMBERS OF THE HIGHWAY
PATROL COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES --
MEMBERS WHO SERVED AS DEPUTY
SHERIFFS.
AND THE SURROUNDING --
OFFICERS WELL I'LL BE THERE.
IN PICO RIVERA IN MY DISTRICT.
AND IN LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN ONE
RETIRES CALLED END OF WATCH WHAT
HIS END OF WATCH WHICH TO TWENTY
SEVEN OH TO THE JOINED THE RANKS
pIN UNIFORM.
ON JANUARY NINETEENTH OF THIS
YEAR.
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE HIS WIFE
ADELINA.
REST IN PEACE MY BROTHER.
UNTIL WE MEET AGAIN.
AND FOR THESE REASONS I ASKED WE
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
PLEASE BE SURE TO BRING HIS NAME
FOR ITS WE CAN PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE HIM.
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY FURTHER
ADJOURN IN MEMORIES [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS MADAM PRO TEM.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THE
RULES COMMITEE WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT IN --
OF SESSION IN ROOM.
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE THANK YOU
OTHER FURTHER COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS SEEING NONE.
SORRY CENTER PAN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT --
THE BUDGET --
AND FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER THREE AND HEALTH AND THIS
WILL BE MEETING IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE AT AT TEN AM THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN MEMBERS IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
CENTER ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK THIS WEEK
COLLEAGUES WE WILL --
RECONVENE ON MONDAY AT TWO PM.
EVERYONE HAVE A WONDERFUL
WEEKEND THE SENATE IS IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE AND WE WILL RECONVENE
MONDAY AT TWO PM